السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
يطيبوا لنا نرحب بكم في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بمناسبه عقد القمه العربيه
الصينيه الاولى الهادفه لرفع مستوى
التعاون المشترك بين الدول الاعضاء
بالجامعه الدول العربيه وجمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه بما يخدم المصالح المشتركه لدولنا
كما يسرنا ننقل لكم تحيات سيدي خادم
الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز ال سعود حفظه الله
وتمنياته بنجاح اعمال هذه القمه اصحاب
الجلاله والفخامه والسمو المحالي احنا
علاقه تاريخيه بين الدول العربيه وجمهوريه
الصين الشعبيه قائمه على الاحترام وتبادل
والصداقه والتعاون في العديد والمجالات
وتولدون اهميه قصوى لدعم سياده الطور
والتنميه من اجل تطوير اقتصادياتها شعوبها
وننظر في المنطقه العربيه ببالغ الاهتمام
بالمحقق جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه من نمو
الطرد وتقدم تقني متسارع جعلها ضمن
اقتصاديات الرائده عالميا ويؤسس العقاد
هذه القمه لمرحله جديده للارتقاء للعلاقه
بين دولنا وتعزيز الشراكه في المجالات
التي تحتوي المشترك ومن اجل تحقيق
المستقبل تطمحلال شعوبنا لتنعم الاجيال
القادمه بالرخاء المنشود علينا بواسطه
تحديد التعاون في المجالات التجاريه
واستثماريه والماليه بين الدول العربيه
والصين
في اطارات ثنايا المتعدد وتطوير تنسيق
السياسي على ساحه الدوليه تجاه القضايا
الاقليميه والدوليه ذات احتمال المشترك
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمومه والمعالي
تعمل المملكه على تحديد التعاون الدولي
مواجهه التحديات التي تواجهها عالمنا ودعم
العمل الدوري المتحدد الاطراف في اطار
مبادئ الامم المتحده بممارسه تحقيق
المستقبل واحد الشعوب الاجيال القادمه ان
لمده يكون لحجم الاتحاد الذي مثل التغيير
المناخيمه حلول اكثر اصتدامه وشموليه في
اطار نهر متوازن وسعيده اثار سلبيه مع
المحافظه على مستويات نمو الاقتصاد
العالمي حيث نستهدف الوصول الحياه الكربون
دول تاثير على النمو والسلاسل الامداد
وتثمر المملكه تعاون وشركاه شركات الدوليه
مع الدول العربيه والصين في اطار مبادره
الشرطه الاخضر والماكد استعداد الايجابي
مع المبادرات التي تعزز عملنا البيئي
المشترك مع مراعات المصالح التنمويه الدول
وتفاوته امكانيات بينها وفضل تنامي يحدد
التحديات الدوليه الاخرى من ذلك الامن
الغذائي ومن الطاقه تاتي اهميه الت مع
المبادرات الجاده السائله تنشيط واسترد
التعاون والعمل الجماعي ونثمن دور جمهوريه
الصين الشعبيه بطرح عدد المبادرات القيمه
ومن اهمها وزاره اصدقاء التنميه العالميه
التي تتوافق مع الجوانب عديده معنويات
المملكه تجاه دعم التنميه المستدامه
وتحديد الامن الغذائي
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو المعالي
تتطلب التنميه الاقليميه والدوليه جهود
بيئيه وسياسيه واجتماعيه مستقره وامنه
وتكثيف جهود المجتمع الدولي لمعالج
القضايا الاقليميه الدوليه
وتستمر المملكه جميع الجهود لتعزيز الامن
والاستقرار في المنطقه وتدعم الحلول
السياسيه والحوار لحل النزاعات الاقليميه
والدوليه وتؤكد ضروره وجود حل هذه الودائع
والقضيه الفلسطينيه
وفقرات الشرعيه الدوليه ومضادات السلام
العربيه بما يقفل للشعب الفلسطيني حقه في
اقامه دولته المستقله على حدوثه 67
وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه نقدر موقف الصين
الداعم للحمل دولتين مبادره السلام
العربيه كما تدعم المملكه الجهود الرامي
للوصول سياسي شامل اليمن لانهاء الازمه
اليمنيه وفق مرجعيات الثلاث ونشيد بدائيه
للمبادرات السعوديه تجاه اليمن كما تؤكد
للمملكه اهميه مضاعفه الجهود الراميه حلول
سياسيه لانهاء الازمه في كل من سوريا
وليبيا بما يكمل تحقيق الامن والاستقرار
في البلدين الشقيقين وعودتمايل الدائره
العام العربي المشترك
وفي الختام نجدد تاكيد اهميه مواصل
التعاون العربي الصيني بما يخدم اهدافهم
مشتركه تطلعات شعوبنا والقيام بدور بدوره
وفعال على الساحه الدوليه وان تساهم نتائج
هذه القمه في تحقيق اثار ايجابيه ومستهدفه
في جميع المجالات على المستوى الاقليمي
والدولي مقدرين الامين العام جامعه الدول
العربيه والمسلمين امانه ما يبذلون من
جهود موفقه في هذا الايطالي شكرا
[تصفيق]